Vegeta what does it say about his
subscriber level it's over 20 20 20 the
last couple weeks were like a studying
marathon for me I had 5 finals in a row
in 5 days and that's pretty much the
reason that you see this growing on my
face because when you're studying for 5
finals in a row you don't have time to
shave I'd like to thank everyone for all
the support that you've been giving me
on my youtube channel I really
appreciate everything and I'm just so
glad to have found over 20,000 people
that share similar interests as I do I
know I haven't been able to upload as
many videos as I'd like to but I'm in my
summer session now and that ends June
25th and after that I have a two-month
break where I'm definitely going to be
uploading videos it doesn't mean I'm not
going to be making videos until then but
after June 25th you can expect to see a
lot more videos from me once again thank
you guys so much for all the support
that you've given me
over the last two years and if you're
not already subscribed be sure to
subscribe by clicking the silver button
up there since it's now changed I'll see
you soon
[Music]